hace más de 20 años que Berta llegó a
Estados Unidos desde Nicaragua entró con
una visa de turista para estar 90 días y
no volvió a salir ya lo tenía planeado
quería una vida mejor desde entonces ha
estado trabajando como empleada
doméstica porque no tiene papeles para
vivir legalmente es saber que nos vamos
al trabajo y no sabemos si vamos a
regresar a casa
son tantas situaciones que cada persona
indocumentada pasa en este país mientras
pasan los días y no tenés un documento
de trabajo
ahora Berta Biblia atemorizada por la
nueva ley de Florida contra la migración
irregular impulsada por el gobernador
ron de santis se contemplan penas de
hasta 15 años de prisión a quienes
transporten indocumentados al Estado
imponen multas de mil dólares diarios a
quienes contratenían documentados e
invalidan todas las tarjetas de
identificación salvo la de Florida ella
no puede conducir y se arriesga a ser
arrestada hay mucho temor en la
comunidad y somos nosotros quienes
estamos haciendo el trabajo que los
ciudadanos no quieren hacer mi gente la
nueva ley ha puesto contra las cuerdas a
sectores como el campo o la construcción
donde se estima que trabaja más del 40%
de los indocumentados por eso Muchos ya
están pensando Incluso en cerrar su
negocio ante la previsible falta de
personal si nos afecta porque incluso es
un documentados en los van yo acá Tengo
pensado en cerrar varias semanas o dos o
tres semanas Porque no tenemos mano de
obra
algunos analistas opinan que esta
legislación solo es una estrategia
política de su carrera presidencial de
2024 por el partido republicano Aunque
el gobierno de Florida se defiende dice
que el objetivo de la ley es luchar
contra el tráfico humano se enriquecen
todos estos
coyotes mexicanos
los carteles de la droga los utilizan
como uno de transporte Mientras tanto la
comunidad migrante sin papeles está en
la incertidumbre sin saber cómo se
aplicará realmente esta medida pero
aseguran que lucharán hasta el final y
prometen llevar la ley ante la justicia